Bev had always loved going to the mall.
When she was a child, it meant spending quality
time with her mother, taking in the bustling
sights of the stores, the enticing smells
of the food court.
When she was on her best behavior, she might
be rewarded with a new toy, a soft pretzel,
or a fistful of quarters to spend at the arcade.
When she was a little bit older, first coming
into her independent teenage spirit, the mall
was a place of refuge, of freedom.
Somewhere she could spend time with her friends
away from her family’s prying eyes, trying
on outfits she’d never be allowed to wear
to school, filling up on free samples, and
imagining what it might feel like to be grown
up.
But as Bev had gotten older, left behind childish
things, the mall had started to die.
She knew it wasn't her fault, but it was sad
to watch the source of so many simple joys
whither away bit by bit.
Stores closed one by one, driven out of business
by the convenience of online shopping.
Slowly but surely, the thriving center of
her suburban youth hollowed out, turning into
a graveyard of commerce left behind in the
endless march toward the future.
The colorful signs and advertisements for
coming attractions remained, but there were
no customers.
The phantom smell of uneaten Cinnabon lingered
in the air.
The lights were on, but no one was home.
And then, the lights went out too.
The city didn't want to deal with the abandoned
mall's upkeep, but they didn't want to go
to the trouble of tearing it down, either.
So, they just left it there.
There was a running joke in town that the
last security guard to lock up the place had
left the doors wide open and just let nature
get inside and start taking its course.
The mall belonged to the wild plants and animals
again, a strange, artificial enclosure where
raccoons could scavenge and deer could hide
from hunters and their rifles.
Then, of course, the small town had done what
small towns do best: it fired up the rumor
mill.
Worried parents passed around email forwards
warning about dangerous drifters hiding out
in the empty mall, or gangs conducting violent
initiations there.
Teenagers dared each other to go inside before
chickening out and going home, riling each
other up with promises of ghosts or evil store
mannequins ready to attack.
Children at recess or on scout camping trips
gave each other nightmares with stories of
giant monsters hiding in the old building,
waiting for lost kids to wander inside so
they could gobble them up.
Bev knew none of that was true, it couldn't
be, but she still couldn't shake the curiosity
she felt about the mall that the town had
left behind.
What did it look like now?
What had the elements, the time, the influence
of intruders, both curious and destructive,
done to the place?
She had never planned to get into urban exploring,
but then again, she hadn't planned to move
back to her hometown after flunking out of
law school either.
It was strange, being back in such a familiar
place that now looked so different.
She could try to adjust, could let her life
fade into a gray routine of diner breakfasts
and drinks at the one bar in town and endless
cups of coffee, or she could find a way to
lean into the inherent strangeness of being
back home.
When she bumped into Daniel, her best friend
from high school, and he told her all about
his new, slightly illegal hobby, she knew
she had found the answer.
He had a crew of fellow Urban Explorers, a
term they preferred to use instead of "trespassers,"
a mix of friends from high school and other
exploring enthusiasts he had met online.
Bev was casually interested, but not entirely
sure if the dangerous hobby was for her, until
Daniel mentioned the mall.
Like Bev, he had continued thinking about
it long after its official closing.
He wanted to go inside, to see what had happened
to it over the years, and to see if there
was a crumb of truth to any of the rumors
about what lurked inside.
Bev didn't take that part seriously, but her
fascination with the old mall was enough to
convince her to join the crew on their expedition
inside.
Daniel provided her with a list of rules:
Turn off your cellular data once you get there
so the police can't prove you were trespassing,
bring water, bring a flashlight, and wear
all black.
The group agreed to meet about a mile away
from the old mall, where they would park their
cars, discuss their plans, and head inside.
Bev felt a bit silly, lying to her parents
about where she was going at her age.
But she didn't want them to worry about her.
She told them she was going to meet up with
some friends at a dance club just out of town.
They didn't bother to ask what kind of club
she would wear a black sweater, black pants,
boots, and a black knit hat to.
She was happy to leave without any more scrutiny.
As she drove out toward the abandoned mall,
she gripped the steering wheel with sweaty,
nervous hands.
What was she thinking?
What if something went wrong while they were
in there?
The old building could be full of exposed
wiring, and loose beams just waiting to fall
down and crush someone.
There could be a nest of rabid animals ready
to defend their territory.
She tried to shake off the sense of foreboding.
Daniel and his crew had done this sort of
thing dozens of times before.
Everything would be fine.
By the time she pulled up to the meeting spot
and parked her car, Bev had managed to calm
herself down.
This would be a fun, weird night of poking
around the ruins of her childhood, the remains
of a long-gone piece of suburban Americana,
and that was all.
Nothing bad would happen.
She introduced herself to the rest of the
group, a pair of brothers named Mark and Louis
that she recognized from high school and a
young woman named Rachel who didn't look a
day over 20.
She must have been one of Daniel's internet
buddies.
"Is this everybody?"
Bev asked.
Daniel nodded.
"This is the crew for tonight.
Ready?"
"Ready as I'll ever be."
Bev shrugged and laughed.
Everyone else nodded in agreement, holding
up their various flashlights, excited to get
into the mall and explore.
The place was every bit as fascinating as
Bev had hoped it would be, a mixture of almost
untouched storefronts, clothes rotting off
of their eternal plastic mannequins beneath
plastic signs advertising Going Out of Business
sales, and the wild world encroaching on what
had once been a piece of suburban retail paradise.
Spiderwebs hung along the walls, possums and
rats skittered along the floors, vines crept
along the remains of the fountain at the center
of the food court that had long ago run dry.
Bev screamed in shock as something ran across
her foot, but when she cast her flashlight
beam at it she found that it was just a small
raccoon, running from the sudden intrusion
on its home.
"Sorry, I'll keep my cool next time."
She laughed it off.
"It's fine.
It happens to me too."
Daniel reassured her.
"You never quite get used to roaming around
these places in the dark.
But look, there's a lot of cool stuff to check
out."
He used his flashlight to illuminate the food
court, specifically the soft pretzel stand.
On top of the stand, leaning precariously
to one side, was the enormous model of a soft
pretzel that had once attracted hungry shoppers
looking for a snack.
"Hungry?"
He quipped.
Bev couldn't help herself, she pulled out
her phone and snapped a picture.
It was creepy, it was a little sad, but mostly
it was a reminder of the simple joys of childhood.
When the flash went off, it illuminated the
darkness behind the stand, and she caught
the glow reflecting in the eyes of the animals
hiding back there.
It unsettled her at first, but she reminded
herself, this place was theirs now.
She and Daniel and everyone else, they were
just visiting for the night.
She checked her phone to see how the picture
came out, and frowned.
"Hey, Daniel?
Look at this."
She held out her phone to show him, and his
eyes widened.
"What is that?
Can you zoom in?"
Bev zoomed in on the picture, and the two
took a closer look.
There, in the background of the picture, just
barely illuminated by the phone's flash, was
a large silhouette.
They couldn't make out any defining features
other than a large, round head, and long,
thin, noodle-like arms.
"Did this place used to have a mascot, or
something?"
Daniel asked.
Bev shook her head.
"Not that I remember."
"Huh."
Daniel sighed.
"Weird.
Anyway.
Where'd the others go?"
He looked around for their flashlights, or
any other sign of life.
"Guys?
Did you get lost?"
His voice echoed through the wide, empty space,
but no one responded.
"Hello?!"
Bev called out, a chill running down her spine.
Only minutes ago, she had heard the others
laughing and joking around as they explored
the other end of the mall, but now she couldn't
hear a thing.
Even the chittering of the rats had gone quiet.
Suddenly, a bloodcurdling scream rang out,
and sent Bev's heart leaping into her throat.
She and Daniel shared a look of deep concern
as they both silently wondered if their worst
fears had come to pass.
Had someone fallen?
Had there been an accident?
She and Daniel followed the sound, looking
for the source.
"Are you guys okay?"
Daniel shouted.
The lack of response spoke volumes.
Whatever had happened, the rest of the group
was in big trouble.
Bev quietly kicked herself for neglecting
to bring a first aid kit.
Finally, the two reached the other end of
the mall, where the scream had sounded like
it was coming from.
But there was no one there.
Only a dark, wet smear along the ground.
It looked incredibly fresh, and it smelled
metallic, violent.
Bev didn't have to look more closely to tell
that it was blood.
Whatever had happened to the other three...she
wasn't sure they were going to find them alive.
Daniel reached into his jacket pocket and
pulled out a small pocket knife.
"It's not much, but... just in case."
He held it out in front of them as they walked,
following the trail of blood.
Something crashed to the ground behind them,
and Bev whirled around to see a large steel
beam only feet away.
Any closer, and they would have been crushed.
Her eyes darted around, searching for any
more potential danger, and then...she saw
it.
Up in the rafters, by the ceiling, was a strange
figure.
It was unlike anything she had ever seen.
It was tall, impossibly tall, and pitch black.
Its head was bulbous, with a pair of feline
ears on top.
She could make out a nose, a pair of wide
white eyes with big dark pupils, and it was
smiling.
A broad, wicked smile, filled with jagged
blood-stained teeth.
Its hands looked like enormous white gloves.
It was almost like...she felt ridiculous thinking
this even as terror prickled at the back of
her neck, but it looked like an old cartoon,
the sort of thing her grandmother used to
watch.
Except that those always looked friendly,
even if they were a little unsettling.
This thing...it looked evil.
At first, she thought it was some sort of
twisted graffiti or a statue left by a macabre
experimental artist.
But then, it moved.
The creature tilted its head to the side,
its smile broadening and its pupils dilated.
It was looking right at her, and it was excited.
"Daniel..."
Bev whispered weakly.
"I see it too."
He replied, his voice shaking.
"We need to go.
We need to go now."
Bev couldn't be sure what the thing would
do if it caught them, but she didn't want
to wait around to find out.
She grabbed Daniel's arm, and yanked him toward
the exit.
It took him a moment to start moving again,
paralyzed by fear and confusion at the incomprehensible
sight of the entity on the ceiling, but once
he started running, it seemed like he would
never stop.
The two raced toward the exit, arms and legs
pumping as fast as they could.
Behind them, they could hear the creature
chasing after them, but they didn't dare look
back to see.
Just before they passed the threshold out
of the mall, Bev felt Daniel's hand slip out
of hers.
She spun around, searching for him, and watched
in helpless terror as the long, long arms
of the creature looped around his chest, pulling
him back away from her and lifting him up
in the air.
It opened its massive mouth, wider, wider,
wider, and swallowed him whole.
Bev screamed, but she forced herself to keep
running, to save herself from the same fate.
She could feel the entity's eyes on her back
as she ran out the door, but once she escaped,
she knew it would not chase her any further.
For some reason...it was letting her go.
She couldn't imagine it was out of some kind
of mercy, but she was grateful to escape with
her life just the same.
Bev stumbled into the local police station
a disheveled mess, face streaked with tears,
and told the officer on duty what she had
seen.
He didn't believe her at first, asking her
to repeat her story again and again.
Every time, she insisted that she knew what
she encountered out there.
Or, at least, she knew that she couldn't explain
it.
The officer sat her in an interrogation room
alone with a cup of coffee, and asked her
to wait until someone more qualified to help
her arrived.
She wondered if they were going to try and
have her committed, if they had assumed she
had lost her mind.
But when a man in a white lab coat opened
the door and greeted her, he said that he
believed her.
He wasn't from a hospital, or affiliated with
the police.
He was from a special organization, a Foundation
dedicated to investigating the unexplained.
He was going to look into what happened at
the mall.
All he asked was that she tell him, in her
own words, what she had seen.
"I don't know."
She sighed.
"It looked like...some kind of messed up cartoon
cat."
With the first-hand account of Bev, and a
series of confirmed disappearances that could
all be traced to the abandoned mall, the SCP
Foundation opened an official investigation.
Wanting to eliminate as many potential complications
as possible, the Foundation selected only
one researcher actually enter the abandoned
building, an operative with a great deal of
field work experience named Dr. Baughan.
Though Dr. Baughan would be entering the building
alone, he would not be without support.
He would be fitted with a microphone and camera,
and his progress would be monitored remotely
by a supervisor at a nearby Foundation site.
If the need for backup arose, they would then
be able to deploy additional security officers
to enter the mall and extract Dr. Baughan
if at all possible.
He would also be armed, with a standard pistol
as well as a Foundation-issued flamethrower.
With the team selected, and the appropriate
safety measures taken, it was time for Dr.
Baughan to enter the mall and see just what
he could learn about the entity dwelling inside.
If at all possible, he was to neutralize it
and bring it into containment alive so that
it could be studied closely in a clinical
environment.
If live capture was impossible, he was instructed
to terminate the being and bring its body
in for a thorough autopsy.
With his weapon already drawn and ready, and
his eyes sharp and alert, Dr. Baughan walked
into the empty mall.
He saw a lot of what Bev and her friends had
seen: the old pretzel stand, the dried-up
fountain, the creepy but harmless rows of
faceless mannequins still locked in the same
poses they had held for a decade.
The spiderwebs made him a little nervous,
but that was garden-variety arachnophobia
more than any sense of real danger.
"I don't know about this one, honestly."
He spoke into his microphone to his supervisor
on the other end.
"So far, seems like this place is your standard
abandoned building death trap, maybe our missing
persons just weren't careful or properly trained
to deal with navigating a place like this."
"Just keep looking."
His supervisor ordered.
"Look for anything anomalous."
"Got it."
Dr. Baughan nodded.
He stepped on something with a loud CRUNCH.
He looked down to see the oldest, stalest
soft pretzel he had ever seen.
"Anyone hungry?"
He quipped, turning his camera toward the
unappetizing sight.
"Don't worry, I'll keep looking."
He carried on walking, heading past a shoe
store, a music store, some kind of novelty
porcelain figurine store.
He stopped at the toy store when something
eerie caught his eye.
"You guys seeing this?"
He asked.
"What is it, Baughan?"
His supervisor replied.
"Just this creepy stuffed animal thing.
The cat, right over there.
I don't like how its eyes follow me when I
walk by."
"I don't see a cat."
Sure enough, when Dr. Baughan did a double-take,
the strange cat-like toy was nowhere to be
seen.
"Well, there's your first anomalous activity..."
He joked, though his heart was beginning to
pound nervously in his chest.
"Keep looking."
He nodded, and continued his patrol of the
area.
He couldn't get the face of that thing that
wasn't a toy out of his head.
Its eyes, like the old Felix the Cat clock
his grandparents had in their guest room.
That thing had scared the hell out of him
as a kid, he could never sleep in the room
with it.
All he could think about were its eyes going
back and forth, back and forth.
He stopped in his tracks.
He thought he could hear the sound of a ticking
clock, clear as day, just behind him.
He turned to look, but there was no clock.
Nothing but darkness and emptiness, the same
as everywhere else.
He felt something suddenly tugging at his
foot.
He looked, expecting to see an animal pulling
at his shoelace, something ordinary, but instead...He
saw long, pointed fingers curling around his
ankle.
He couldn't see what the fingers belonged
to, couldn't see a body, could only see a
long, looping snake of a shadowy arm curling
around the corner up ahead.
Before he could tell his supervisor what was
happening, the hand had grabbed hold of him
and was dragging him across the ground.
The hand lifted him off the floor, then dropped
him back down.
He felt the lens of his camera break.
"Are you ok?
We lost visuals."
"No!
No, I'm not!"
He shouted, as he looked up into the face
of pure evil.
Its pupils were dark and endless, its eyes
bloodshot, its teeth bared.
"Don't send in backup, repeat, do NOT send
in backup!
Oh god, oh god-"
The audio cut to static, and the signal was
lost.
Dr. Baughan's body was never found.
The entity referred to as Cartoon Cat was
given the object class Keter, regarded as
highly dangerous and nearly impossible to
contain due to its reality-bending nature.
Because it cannot be physically contained,
the Foundation's solution to minimize Cartoon
Cat's damage was to block off access to the
abandoned mall.
All civilians were warned of a deadly amount
of radiation in the area, in order to deter
them from conducting any more urban exploration,
vandalism, or other visits to the location.
Any of the few survivors that have encountered
Cartoon Cat are given amnestics, and their
experiences are written off as substance-related
or vivid nightmares.
The empty mall may not be the only place Cartoon
Cat has made its own.
Nor is it likely to be the only building of
its kind that houses an anomalous monster.
After all, when humanity decides to vacate
a place, to leave it standing vacant and abandoned,
you never know what might decide to move in.
Now go check out “SCP-096 VS Siren Head”
and “SCP-4158 - Big Charlie” for more
things made by the inimitable Trevor Henderson!